How do you fight endometrial lung cancer?
So, you know, this person asked this question the last time, a little different way.
But I think you're asking endometrial cancer that has metastasized to the lung, because
the endometrial is a distance away from the lung.
I mean, from endometrial cancer that was removed in 2012 from a total misdirectomy, do you
fight it with formal therapy or chemo or a lot?
You know, it's not a question I can just answer real simply on a list of health hours
here.
So you need to work with either our clinic or a clinic that's going to treat you as far
as looking at your whole picture.
So, if you have endometrial cancer that was treated in 2012, and now it's metastasized
to the lung, and how would you know that, is if you have lung issues, if they see a
mass, they do a biopsy, and it's actually endometrial cancer in the lung.
So lots of times people realize that when you have metastasis of a cancer to another spot
in the body, it's still that same cancer.
So, how would we treat that?
Again, we don't treat cancer, but we treat the person, and how would we care for somebody
with metastatic cancer is we certainly use right technology, and we'd use nutrition
to diet and work along with your oncologist, if you're going to be working with an oncologist.
Can you use formal therapy, well, if it was estrogen receptor positive or progesterone
receptor positive or two positive in the first place, and they did another biopsy of this
one, they should be checking whether it's hormone positive or negative with this one, because
just because it was with the first one does not mean it is with this one, so formal therapy
might have no effect on it.
Would you use chemo, or what possibly totally depends on the person, depends on what's
going on there's, I just can't answer that, and I'm not a practitioner that is completely
against Cuba, but I think you should be doing other things as well.